we got the story this Twitter thread
from Matt saibi and it's all right here
check this out
Post Number 20 of today's Twitter files
this post is about the hunter Biden
laptop situation shows that Roth yellow
Roth not only met weekly with the FBI
and DHS but with the office of the
Director of National Intelligence take a
look at this
this post the most important thing it
says in short FML weekly sync with FBI
DHS dni re-election security the meeting
happened about 15 minutes after the
aforementioned hack materials implosion
blah blah blah that right there says one
thing very very simply
Twitter was regularly meeting with
federal law enforcement for
quote-unquote election security but
Twitter was being advised that there was
going to be hacked materials and other
things like that we've we know that the
FBI contacted them specifically about
that we now know they had consistent
weekly meetings to the point where they
were actually like oh man gonna have to
meet uh miss our weekly meet up with
federal law enforcement to figure out
what's what's not allowed this Twitter
thread is actually very very crazy
there's one post where let me see if I
can I can uh there's so many of these
look at this one yoel Roth said
very boring business meeting that is
definitely not about Trump pretty much
definitely not meeting with the FBI I
swear LMAO it would sound and it would
appear I'm trying to be very careful
that Joel Roth met with the FBI to
discuss Donald Trump I wonder what this
was pertaining to this Twitter thread
from Matt TYB is specifically about
banning Donald Trump he says after j6
internal slacks Show Twitter Executives
getting a kick out of intensified
relationships with federal agencies
here's Joel Roth lamenting a lack of
generic enough calendar descriptions to
concealing his very interesting meeting
Partners sounds to me like the FBI was
meeting with Twitter and uh they
colluded ultimately to come to the
decision to remove Donald Trump the
first sitting head of state to be
suspended from a platform and aside from
that the other information showing that
they were having regular 2020 election
security meetings
and we know that the FBI warned about
the hunter Biden lapid situation and
they had access to this so to me I think
this is the bare minimum confirmation
the FBI was directly interfering in the
2020 election
I mean it's pretty clear after all the
circumstantial evidence is coming
together and there's a lot of it
specifically highlighting the
involvement of this and I I kind of want
to bring back what U.S congressman Chuck
Schumer said a couple years ago in 2017
when he was directly addressing Donald
Trump When Donald Trump was having
problems with the Intel agencies with
the FBI he said quote the Intel
officials have six ways from Sunday at
getting back at you so I think it's fair
to say that there was a lot of
infighting and it's fair to say that
there was federal agencies Intel
organizations Military psyops Officers
that were working at these big Tech
social media companies there was a
revolving door between all those
institutions and a lot of these bigger
companies not just Twitter but also
Facebook also alphabet also Google and
when you look at this revolving door you
clearly see a conflict of interest
people abusing their power not just
meeting together but making big
decisions and this is what I said when
the first Twitter files were coming out
I'm like this is just bare minimum this
is still just scratching the surface as
there was a former FBI agent that was
that was critically involved in this
whole Trump collusion story that was
involved in censoring it from the very
beginning so so so now I think we're
seeing some of the layers of this onion
unravel a lot of people are going to be
crying and I I think we're still only
seeing the surface of what's a deeper
relationship between the Intel community
and of course big Tech social media that
are working hand in hand together I've
mentioned oh that it's happened before
and and that I feel like but we talk
about how like it's frog in the pot
boiling the water's boiling slowly and
we don't feel it heating up because it's
happening so slowly but think about
Nixon man the last time we had a corrupt
government spying
explosive news piece it was Nixon well
it wasn't that wasn't the last time but
Nixon and Watergate he resigned the
presidency because he was found spying
on another campaign do you remember uh
when President Trump was uh still
president there was some legislative
Bill put in to against big Tech and it
went into the Senate and they knocked it
down he warned about out all this all
the censorship and it didn't get passed
through the Senate no do you remember
that well was it it was you remember Tim
no I was going to say from 2016 to 2018
the Republicans were actively working
against Trump exactly and especially
with big Tech because I know he warned
them about it and they didn't follow
through when they could have when they
had control now you know there's no
control I'm sorry I need to clarify
they've always been working against
Trump but I mean when they had full
control of of the of the senate in the
house they were going along with the
whole Russia gate lies and all of its
stuff check us I want to show you guys
this tweet from um Matt's Ivey check
this out
here the FBI sends reports about a pair
of tweets the second of which involves a
former typical Tippecanoe County Indiana
counselor and Republican named John
Basham claiming between 2 and 25 of
ballots by mail are being rejected for
errors
so they said
here we just got a report from the FBI
concerning two tweets related to the
shredding of mail-in ballots this has
proven to be false via this PolitiFact
do we have a moment ready for this one I
believe this was deemed no vo on
numerous occasions so this is the FBI
contacting Twitter saying remove this
guy's speech on what grounds PolitiFact
says it's not true
but on what Authority does the federal
government have to flag the speech of a
private individual to be removed from a
platform zero none period it's pure
corruption look I I don't like the idea
of misinformation I think PolitiFact is
full of Trap full of garbage they lie
all the time
the fact that partisan leftist
organizations can claim something's not
true the FBI then goes to Twitter and
Twitter says oh look at that guess we
got to remove it this is this is
um some people are saying collusion
other people are saying conspiracy I
think all you know all those references
could be true they use PolitiFact as
proof they use the word this is quote
proven you don't take one news article
and use that as quote proof like you
need to you need to look around if
you're going to make a big decision like
that like ending someone's twitter
experience you gotta know you can't just
willy-nilly say like you know this piece
of evidence indicates true proof that's
a big problem they don't have the assets
to do it who doesn't the FBI they could
look into anything you know they
shouldn't just be gone by one news they
don't I think at this point
um we can clearly see the FBI is is
effectively only going after their
political enemies yeah I think what
really happened is that they saw an
article that they liked that that
verified what they wanted to be true so
they said it was proof but I mean on it
you cannot no human realistically can
look at one news article and use that as
a piece of proof for something that's
ridiculous after the uh the plethora of
crimes committed against uh us here as
well as people on our periphery if the
FBI lifted a single finger I might be
inclined to give them the benefit of the
doubt and say you know it's these bad
apples in DC but at this point
considering you've got Marjorie Taylor
green being swatted seemingly no action
we've been swatted now I think like 15
times no action and there's been other
crimes in the periphery of the work we
do with people we know and zero action
to the point where I've actually had
people say to me when we're talking
privately I can't say some of this stuff
because I'm hoping something does get
involved like something does happen with
law enforcement but I've had people say
to me like whether the FBI do anything
about that and I'm like no of course
they didn't it's been two years and
there's there's nothing being done so so
I will just say at this point I think
it's fair to say the FBI is not going to
do anything they'll go after a garage
poll rope for a for a NASCAR driver that
but but they're not going to deal with
the the seriousness of crimes they're
going to directly this is them directly
interfering in the election like it is a
criminal organizationally tell you what
happened personally to my family with
the FBI there were two tips called in to
the FBI about my daughter's shooter and
they dropped the ball on both of them
wow they didn't follow up was the
shooters going to be a shooter was the
shooter uh a Democrat or you know it was
just a piece of garbage you know but
they called in they called it in twice
to the FBI and they dropped the ball
they ended up getting held accountable
they they're actually one of the only
entities that admitted failure in the
shooting but they also and they do and
that happens in many shootings you know
they were constantly dropping the ball
but what's their concern with Twitter
you know what I mean there's people
getting shot and and here they are
censoring and working with Twitter when
they're dropping the ball on mass
shootings you're specifically mentioning
the parking shooter is that correct
correct because we see this time and
time again known to authorities there's
so many instances where he was either uh
undercover or working or known to uh
local police officers state officers or
in the most situations let's be honest
here Federal officials federal
government officials especially at the
FBI uh who were warned many times and
it's just it's just mind-boggling and
and head scratching for the average
citizen to be like oh he was known again
and they and they didn't stop it but if
there's an abortion activist if there's
a parent-teacher conference activist
they're going to be on them like white
on rice they're going to be
investigating them spying on them them
they're going to be jailing people just
like they are for peacefully singing
hymns outside of abortion clinics that's
what the FBI is spending their resources
on right now but but all these mass
shootings always go free when we have
the biggest national security
surveillance Dragnet and all of recorded
human history the government sees and
watches almost every aspect of our life
databases it in these huge server rooms
watches over everything and and we're
gonna we're gonna believe them when they
say oh you know this convenient event
that works towards our agenda that gives
us more power and authority now that
more people will have to rely on us on
just accidentally happened we knew you
know we knew that there was a suspect
here but he just fell through the cracks
once again and it happens over and over
I know it's crazy it's absolutely
infuriating thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time